I recently decided to embark on a
spiritual journey to Bali Indonesia it
was a decision I made after a lot of
introspection and a lot of failed
attempts to re-engage with my spiritual
side you see our ability to create
meaning within the modern landscape we
have created is something almost absurd
we just consume consume consume to feel
the void that is constantly generated by
a meaningless life the constant
dissatisfaction that people tend to
exhibit day after day connotes an
extreme lack of spiritual awareness and
a total surrender to the twists and
turns of life I knew that for a long
time I kept feeling it I kept allowing
it to inundate my spiritual system with
the wrong habits and approaches and as a
result I ended up severely disconnected
from my true self Bali looked like the
ideal escape a place so idelic so
picturesque and so far away from my base
that seemed like the perfect destination
for a spiritual cause the moment I
stepped my foot on the island I sensed
its voice calling me the new world was a
strong stimulant for my senses it felt
like I was in a dream a very beautiful
dream that existed solely for the
purpose of reminding me that there are
also other worlds out there
away from eoch chambers away from
dogmatisms away from dominance
hierarchies away from toxic and neurotic
behaviors I was poised to empty my mind
and embark on a journey Beyond Earthly
interpretations of reality and challenge
my cognitive capacity to such a degree
that I could understand even intuitively
what a real connection with the cosmos
feels like I practice meditation and
yoga on a daily basis and by yoga I
don't mean mediocre gymnastics I mean
the spiritual practice that attempts
through a process of Stark immersion in
specific movements and sounds to connect
deeper within yourself and empty your
mind completely if you understand how
powerful this process can be and that is
because most of us are prone to
resistance resistance was is and will
always be an omnipresent Force but at
the end of the day resistance is futile
resistance is nothing more than
manifested scream from your deep self
that seeks to escape the confines of a
limited mode of being resistance is fear
cloaked as protection resistance is lack
of awareness resistance is intellectual
poverty we are the ones that feed
resistance and its byproducts we are the
ones that decide by Omission to neglect
all the riches that spiritual growth has
to offer we are our own worst enemies
but we're also our only chance for
catharsis
during my stay in Bali I attended
various yoga movement and mindfulness
workshops in one of the movement
workshops we had to connect with our
partner in a way that allowed us to
resonate mentally and spatially by
exchanging roles between leading and
following we had to come up with ways to
engage in a simple yet powerful dancing
sequence that was predicated on
intuition the exercise itself was quite
challenging since most of us were not
very accustomed to such an intense
interplay our ability to control our
bodies and our movements while staying
engaged with the other person who is
usually a stranger is something Arcane
and intimidating nonetheless when the
initial discomfort vanishes the
connection and the movement allows both
parties to experience the magical
feeling that is freedom of expression it
is a tribal feeling deeply embedded in
the core of our being after finishing
the workshop I came face to face with a
profound idea the healing process of the
individual especially when this healing
commences with the support of another
person can eventually orchestrate the
healing of the world the world doesn't
need more saviors it needs more healers
it needs people who can realize the
power of healing methods and constantly
exercise these methods the homo sapiens
race is nothing more than the
conglomeration of atomic Expressions
coming together and attempting to
construe the cosmos in a courageous way
this results in a form of mental and
spiritual exhaustion whose consequences
we need to face in perpetuity unless we
find a way to alleviate the suffering of
exhaustion n used to say that when we
are tired we're attacked by ideas we
conquered long ago he couldn't be more
accurate spiritual growth and healing is
the only antidote to the delerious
effects of exhaustion when we heal
ourselves we Heal the World
I briefly discussed resistance before
but more in a spiritual context
resistance when it comes to spirituality
is manifested in the denial of the
individual to identify and eventually
Embrace different modes of being it is a
total acceptance of the conventional
narrative that the world is just a rat
race and a continuous struggle for
survival anything beyond that seems
frivolous and you opan it has been one
of my core beliefs over the past couple
of years that the people who managed to
escape this narrative and risk dealing
with the unknown in an attempt to
transcend The Human Condition are the
ones who lead the most meaningful and
balanced lives regardless the Paradigm
Shift we experience on a cultural level
will inevitably urge even the most
resistant ones to reframe their approach
moreover resistance is also manifested
in the way one deals with the darkest
aspects of our Psych
the shadow will persist no matter how
hard one resists it or ignores it it is
such a potent force that the only sure
remedy against it is diagnosis and
collision when you resist you become
disenchanted and you fail to identify
how relevant the shadow is to your
spiritual growth it is only through
spirituality that the balance between
our capacity for good and our capacity
for evil can be
established
when I was younger around the age of 27
I had a girlfriend she was Ginger blonde
with freckles and a magnetic smile she
was younger than me almost 5 years
younger before I met her I didn't really
believe in romantic relationships I had
some but none of them could affect me
deeply I met her by accident at a party
even though our interaction wasn't
something spectacular the relationship
we created later said seduced me
intensely it was one of those
relationships that you decide to give
yourself totally to another person and
you become so vulnerable that you're
literally at their Mercy when you're
together the rest of the world is in
essence non-existent you have created
this subblime Ensemble and you
desperately try to protect the ideal
nature of your relationship a Utopia
that blurs the limits between the
magical and the otherworldly when you
decide to become so vulnerable for
someone else it is a big deal for you
inside the adversities and the ugliness
of the world you feel like you
discovered a safe space a beautiful
soless that makes you feel secure just
like when you were a child the beauty of
our relationship lasted only for 6
months like it was pre-programmed by an
external force or entity to wake me up
from my dream and enforce reality upon
me everything happy playful and carefree
was replaced by something aggressive
divisive and negative as if we both
decided that we had to be hostile to
each other and to adopt a defensive
stance in order to protect our own
version of the truth we both had our
reasons we were both right we were both
really hurt the situation lasted for 3
years and that's not because I couldn't
leave but because I didn't want to I did
not want to lose what I experienced in
the first 6 months I did not want to
believe that something so beautiful can
be lost I didn't want to give up after
some point however I was tired of trying
I had lost all willingness to live and
all desire to see the world as it really
outside the bubble I had created when I
finally left and returned to reality I
felt empty and numb this relationship
wasn't good for me but at the same time
it was the relationship that allowed me
to witness even for a brief moment in
time what a real connection with another
human being feels like the period of
pain s suceeding the period of ecstasy
helped me realize that if a couple
rejects the spiritual nature of their
relationship and allows Earthly issues
to take over there is no future
whatsoever between them through
spirituality you learn to control your
impulses and restrict your ego to such a
degree that any toxic Behavior can be
avoided on demand we didn't know that
our egos were so big and our
constitutions so dissimilar that any
attempts to unite Under the Umbrella of
love was almost organically
rebuffed today after all these years I
understand something very fundamental
about relationships if you decide to
stay loyal to a person and not allow
your feral nature to take over you only
need spirituality to survive and thrive
in the relationship especially if you
decide to embark on a spiritual journey
together and show empathy and support
the ideal relationship isn't just
feasible but I would dare to say the
Catalyst for your your spiritual growth
and
[Music]
freedom
say let
[Music]
see man I see B plug the strongest and
smartest men who've ever
lived I see all his potential and I see
squander God damn it an entire
generation pumping gas waiting tables
slaves white
collars advertising has is chasing cars
and clothes working jobs we hate so we
can buy we don't
need for the middle children of History
man no purpose of
place we have no Great War no Great
Depression our Great War is a spiritual
war our Great Depression
our
lives this is a quote from Fight Club a
movie so prophetic that I get concerned
every time I watch it concerned because
I don't know if a movie can predict
future events or if the movie itself can
become the Catalyst for the emergence of
those events modern societies seem
unable to offer the level of meaning
demanded by our complicated nature we
seek and we find and we seek again and
we find again in the end we rarely
discover answers that can truly satisfy
our
curiosity the next question is bigger
than the last one and the lack of proper
explanations creates an intellectual and
spiritual
void this void becomes an extension of
our Persona and manifests itself in in
behaviors that connote moral relativism
and a deep anger towards our
creator the more dissatisfaction we
experience the more the void grows
bigger it grows bigger until it
transforms into a merciless pit that
will swallow us
[Music]
all the D of Consciousness was either a
mistake or a gift no one can really tell
it was a gift because we're now able to
be in absolute control of our world it
was a mistake because we have no idea
why we do what we
do the aimless pursuit of goals dreams
and Visions can keep one alive but it
doesn't necessarily make this life
pleasurable at the end of the day every
self-aware person realizes that our war
is spiritual and that our depression is
our
lives through spiritual practices we can
reframe the context of the lives we
decide to lead and eventually ameliorate
our
experience all the maladies infringed
Upon Us exist more in our heads than in
reality erroneous thinking and eratic
behaviors that are constantly showcased
in mainstream media and are consequently
adopted by social agents are nothing
more than a
distraction heterodox approaches can act
as a life jacket within a spiritually
dry landscape whilst in spiritual mode
you can more closely examine the melody
of the cosmos the sparkling allegories
of nature the big ass truths of The
Human Condition wrapped in the heart
shell of nonsensical abstraction
themes that flow through the air with
the greatest of ease outside of that
state you're just deaf and losting the
ubiquitous noise of everyday
[Music]
Dil when you succeed in silencing the
noise and allowing the signal to pass
through the cosmos can reveal all its
Secrets all the nuances of every element
that might seem in insignificant
throughout the conventional narrative
seizes its insignificance and it morphs
into pure cosmic
energy you close your eyes and you just
listen and feel the darkness starts to
take shape and weird patterns slowly
emerge what you experience doesn't make
sense Your Capacity to understand is
based solely on
intuition this is how you connect with
the unknown the chaotic nature of the
cosmos seems so seductive and inviting
that you can't
resist it is this state that you have
been seeking for so long its Essence
sounds like poetry to your cow ears you
lack knowledge but your intuition seems
enough you try to understand where are
you what's your purpose what is
this to which the cosmos replies it is
you it is a response so simple yet so
profound that it has completely painted
over the canvas of your mental
imagery you are the anthropomorphic
manifestation of the cosmos expressing
itself in a poetic
[Music]
way
om
shant